[Music]
one of the key themes and one of the key
plot points and trajectories in ursula k
le guin's novel a wizard of earthsea has
to do with this entity we can't even
call it a creature necessarily
that is brought not into being but at
least into the world of earthsea
through the agency of the young wizard
sparrowhawk or ged
and it it starts to be prefigured early
on in chapter two and then we see more
prefiguration in chapter three and then
finally in chapter four
it is brought through a rift that we'll
explore in just a moment
between the worlds of life and death
between light and darkness
and it's an enigmatic entity you can't
even say creature because
was it created by anything nobody really
knows
can it be named can it not be named
there's a lot of uncertainty about it
but there is one thing
that is clear it is evil and it wants to
do evil through young gad or sparrowhawk
and so
if we're looking just at well what kind
of creature is this and how does it get
here there's some some things that we
can explore in chapter two when ged is
studying with with ogian the mage of ray
alby
on the island of gant
he is cajoled into
doing a spell or researching a spell
rather
by a young
daughter of an enchantress who may be
partly a witch herself at this point ojn
says the girl herself is half a witch
herself and and what happens he's being
goaded and so he goes to looking for a
spell of self-transformation and he
can't find what he's looking for these
books were very ancient ogen having them
from his own master haleth farseer and
halath from his master the mage of
paragol sold back into the times of myth
and so ghettos is trying to read these
as he read it puzzling out the runes and
symbols one by one
a horror came over him his eyes were
fixed and he could not lift them till he
had finished reading
all the spell
and this there's a couple things going
on here
so he's being
compelled in a certain way but this
sensation of
horror this affect that is going to
run throughout this and it's kind of a
warning oh you're dealing with this this
bad thing
here's how it continues then raising his
head he saw it was dark in the house he
had been reading without any light in
the darkness he could not now make out
the runes when he looked down at the
book yet the horror grew in him seeming
to hold him bound in his chair he was
cold looking over his shoulder he saw
that something was crouching beside the
closed door a shapeless clot of shadow
darker than the darkness it seemed to
reach out towards him and to whisper and
to call him in a whisper but he could
not understand the words and he's saved
here by ogian coming in the door was
flung wide a man entered with a white
light flaming about him a great bright
figure who spoke aloud fiercely and
suddenly the darkness and the whispering
ceased and were
dispelled and ogeon actually tells them
you will never work that spell but in
peril of your power and your life was it
for that spell you opened the books and
god says no no i was looking for a
different spell sorry about that right
so that is is something really important
and then this comes up again in chapter
three
when ged is studying with the master
summoner
and it's going to be this spell again
right actually this is in the very
beginning of chapter four i take that
back
so
here's how it reads
as for the calling of real things and
living people and the raising up the
spirits of the dead and the invocations
of the unseen those spells which are the
height of the summoner's art and the
mages power those he meaning the master
summoner
scarcely spoke of them
of to them once or twice ged tried to
lead him to talk a little of such
mysteries but the master was silent
looking at him long and grimly till ged
grew uneasy and said no more the master
summoner doesn't want to go into
conversations
sometimes indeed he ged was uneasy
working even such lesser spells as the
summoner taught him there were certain
runes on certain pages of the lore book
that seemed familiar to him that we did
not remember in what book he'd ever seen
them before there were certain phrases
that must be said in spells of summoning
that he did not like to say
they made him think for an instant of
shadows in a dark room
of a shut door and shadows reaching out
to him from the corner by the door
hastily put such thoughts or memories
aside and went on these moments of fear
and darkness he said to himself were
merely the shadows of his ignorance the
more he learned the less he would have
to fear until finally in his full power
as wizard he need fear nothing in the
world nothing
at all and this is something that ged is
telling himself
about the dangers of of the shadows
he's going to be very very wrong as we
find
out in chapter four we have this wizards
duel between
the
well-positioned you know from a
uh
noble background
a head of ged in many respects
youth jasper who's been kind of a jerk
to him through throughout this time from
the very moment that get walked into
rogue and the raw
more powerful
coming from a low class
and and humble background ged who is
still filled with pride there is a
wizard's duel between the two of them
and get is once again goaded into doing
something that he should not do but this
time it's on a larger
scale so what we find is ged
casting a spell
of summoning and who is he summoning
he is summoning
a spirit from the dead and not just any
old spirit from the dead that of
alpharon and she does in fact appear as
we find out the shapeless mass of
darkness he had lifted split apart it
sundered in a pale spindle of light
gleamed between his opened arms a faint
oval reaching from the ground up to the
height of his raised hands in the oval
of light for a moment their move to form
a human shape a tall woman looking back
over her shoulder her face was beautiful
and sorrowful and full of
fear
this is alpharon
only for a moment did the spirit glimmer
there and then something else comes
through something else which is going to
be the shadow a clot
as she describes it a black shadow comes
through through the rent of the in the
darkness of the earth and night a
ripping open of the fabric of the world
through it blazed a terrible brightness
through that brightness shape and breach
clambered something like a clot of black
shadow quick and hideous and it leaps
straight at gad's face
staggering under the weight of the thing
ged gave a
short horse scream the little otak his
his creature
watching from vetch's shoulder the
animal that had no voice screamed aloud
and also it leaped as if to attack ged
fell struggling and writhing while the
bright rip and the world's darkness
above widened and stretched so things
are getting bigger there's more of a
danger here the boys that watched fled
jasper bent down to the ground hiding
his eyes vegetalone ran to his friend so
only he saw the lump of shadow that
clung to ged tearing at his flesh it was
like a black beast the size of a young
child though it seemed to swell and
shrink and had no head or face only four
talon paws with which it gripped and
tore vetch sobbed with hot sorrow with
horror yet he put his hands out to pull
the thing away from ged before he
touched it he was bound still unable to
move the intolerable brightness faded
slowly the torn edges of the world close
together nearby a voice was speaking as
softly as a tree whispers or a fountain
plays and this is the arc mage nemerle
using his power to heal this rift in the
the the world itself and to dispel the
shadow beast from ghetto it takes off
and it's still out there
in the world this also brings about the
death of the archmage neverlay and his
successor
gentile uh explains to ged after ged
is
you know recovered it takes a long time
for him to recover as well he tells him
some explanations of it
nemerle says
nothing protects you but the power of
the masters here and the defenses laid
on this island that keep the creatures
of evil away if you left now the thing
you loosed would find you at once and
enter into you
and possess you
you would be no man but a gebbeth the
term that ursula kayla green comes up
with here right a puppet doing the will
of the evil shadow which you raised into
the sunlight so
the evil shadow is no longer just a
shadow it can take possession of people
and use them for its own purposes and
a gabbath of an ordinary person would be
bad enough a gabbath of a wizard
armed with all of that knowledge and
control over magical things
that would be a catastrophe for for
earth sea so
get actually says better i had died
and uh
genshir says who are you to judge that
you for whom nemerle gave his life uh
you're gonna do your your work
he also tells them another thing too and
this is really quite important
why did things go so badly well you
could say that the the rot was already
there
in the attempt to use ged to bring this
this shadow in to control him on the
part of the enchantress back in in gantt
but
things have gotten worse
here
denture says
here we go
you have great power in born in you you
used that power
wrongly
you abused your power
to work a spell over which you had no
control not knowing how that spell
affects the balance of light and dark
life and death good and evil now gentile
doesn't know that this is already a
spell that has been planted
in gad's mind earlier on in chapter two
but he does know that get is sort of
what we you know sometimes refer to as a
loose cannon
right and he goes on and he says
you were moved to do this by pride and
by hate is it any wonder the result was
ruined and there's an important lesson
here when you're motivated by these
negative affects
even good magic can go bad it's probably
worse when it's already kind of risky
dangerous magic finally he says you
summoned a spirit from the dead okay so
you succeeded in that part of the spell
but with it came one of the powers of
unlife this is different than a spirit
of the dead this is a
entity that has that didn't live at one
time it's unlife it's the opposite of
life and he says uncalled it came from a
place where there are no names
evil it wills to work evil through you
the power you had to call it gives it
power over you you are connected so this
is
setting the stage for the rest of the
work
while ged is still engaged in his
studies we find two important things
that add a little bit more
information there is a
story in one of the lore books
it says from the masters and from
ancient lore books ged learned what he
could about such beings as this shadow
he had little was there to learn
no such creature was described or spoken
of directly there were at best hints
here and there in the old books of
things that might be like the shadow
beast
it was not a ghost of a human man
nor was it a creature of the old powers
of earth yet it seemed it might have
some link with these
in the matter of the dragons which ged
read very closely there was a tale of an
ancient dragon lord who had come under
the sway of one of the old powers a
speaking stone that lay in a far
northern land and we're going to get
introduced to this later on as the
pteranodon right
at the stones command said the book he
did speak to raise up a dead spirit out
of the realm of the dead but his
wizardry being bent awry by the stone's
will there came with it the dead spirit
a thing not summoned which did devour
him from within and in his shape
walked destroying man but the book did
not say what the thing was nor did it
tell the end of the tale
so that's a key bit of information there
we also find out the masters don't
really know that much about it
they don't know where a shadow might
come from the art mage had said from
unlife whatever that is
uh the wrong side of the world said the
master changer the master summoner says
i don't know i don't know where this
thing comes from
and the summoner tells him a few things
that are very important as well
he says
the summoner was grim and grave as ever
but ged now knew his compassion and
loved him well i don't know i know of
the thing only this only a great power
could have summoned up such a thing
perhaps only one power only one voice
your voice but what in turn that means i
do not know you will find out you must
find out or die and worse than die and
there we get a
reference back to what ged thought as as
a young man you thought as a boy that a
mage is one who can do anything
so i thought once so did we all and the
truth is that as a man's real power
grows and as his knowledge widens
ever the way he can follow grows
narrower
until at last he chooses nothing
but does only and holy
what he must do
very interesting thing to to say
is it not so god now is on a path tied
to this shadow being that he has brought
forward being a mage doesn't mean being
able to do anything and not fearing
anything as a matter of fact he now has
his destiny at least a part of it the
destiny that we find elaborated through
the rest of a wizard of earth
set out for him by this action of
bringing the shadow
into being
you